one of the woman you know what she she
said to me she sent a video of herself
walking unveiled and she said that my
mom is scared that I'm gonna be another
massage and I told my mom that mom
you're worried that I'm gonna get killed
like my saw I'm already a dead person
when I don't have freedom when I don't
have freedom to choose what I want to
wear when I don't have freedom to dance
when I don't have freedom to sing when I
don't have freedom to go to Stadium I'm
a dead person
[Music]
foreign
it is my distinct privilege to Welcome
to the podcast uh author activist uh
she's been in the news lately for the
darkest of possible reasons which is
that the Iranian government
hired three people to kill her here in
New York City Massie elenajad welcome
masi thank you so much such an
introduction but you forgot to call me a
troublemaker for molas well you you've
been a troublemaker for quite some time
you also wrote a book which I want to
say is now in the spotlight uh the wind
in my hair my fight for freedom in
modern Iran
um so you've been the leader and really
the Catalyst for a movement against the
compulsory wearing of the hijab in Iran
for years and years now and immigrated
to the U.S in 2009 is that right 2009 I
left Iran so I was in London when I
launched a campaign against compulsory
job but let me be very honest with you I
didn't have any plan to launch a
campaign against compulsory job because
my main focus was uh to give voice to
those whose beloved one got killed in
2009 protest and clearly I was a
political journalist so I was
brainwashed for years and years that
compulsory job is a small issue so one
day my social media was like full of sad
news sorrow you know killings executions
I just published a picture of myself to
cheer my audiences up like to to just
talk about Hope and I the picture was me
running in a beautiful Street full of
blossoms in London and I published that
and I just wrote simple caption anytime
when I run in a free country and I feel
the wind in my hair it just reminds me
of the time that this massive hair was
like a hostage in the hands of the
Iranian regime and then I received a lot
of comments from Iranian women envying
at my freedom from compulsory that's it
immediately I said that wow these women
want to speak up against compulsory job
then soon after I published another
picture of myself which was taken inside
Iran unveiled then I asked Iranians
whether they want to publish their own
photos without hijab I got bombarded by
photos videos of women walking unveiled
which is a punishable crime that's how
my stealthy Freedom Campaign was born oh
that that has been in the news recently
because there's been this wave of
protests in the wake of it sounds like
the one of the catalysts was that the
Iranian National Guard saw a woman
without uh I saw amini got killed in the
hand of morality police that actually
makes me very sad because I mean how
could it it's horrifying to think about
no no I mean people take a woman captive
and then she would die in there not only
that my heart is broken for maso I mean
like millions of other women and that's
why men and women got Furious they took
back to the streets but when you say
that it was on the news the compulsory
hijab thing recently because of her
brutal death that makes me really sad
and Furious because for years and years
um we the women of Iran through our
campaign have been warning the rest of
the world about the danger of morality
police and we've been ignored but
immediately when we are victims so media
pay attention to us when women are
warriors then maybe ignore it so yeah
um through another campaign which I
launched in 2014 white Wednesdays women
were waving what white head scarf in
public walking unveiled and filming the
morality police four of them are still
in prison terrible one of them was only
20 years old but she received 24 years
present
yeah yeah you've had family members in
Iran in prison because of your activism
is that right it's it's because of uh my
uh social media giving voice to Iranian
Brave uh people they hate that they did
everything to make me miserable to um
keep me silent so that's why first they
went after the women of my campaign like
as I told you sabaga they arrested I
felt guilty sure she was only 20 years
old and I didn't know what to do
immediately her mother
sent me a video and saying that now I am
the voice of my daughter and I was like
wait a minute then why should I keep
silent when her mother see that her
daughter got arrested saying that I'm
gonna be her voice so they arrested 29
women of white Wednesday's campaign only
in one day I was like what I'm gonna do
you you feel that like you burden on
your shoulder yes the Iranian regime
brought 11 women on TV to to denounce me
you feel
like miserably guiltiness on your
shoulder you don't know what to do but
what I see that brave women are not
giving up I said to myself I'm not going
to give up so they went after my family
that's why well they've also come after
you there have been two documented
attempts on your life including uh the
most recent one this gets very very real
where uh uh Thug with an automatic rifle
was stationed outside of your house in
Brooklyn uh and did you see the video of
the big guy with loaded gun in front of
him I did and it was it was
extraordinary and very very dark for the
average American the prospect of the
Iranian government hiring assassins to
kill an American on the streets of New
York and one of the things you said was
that if they had opened fire they might
have killed your uh your step children
your neighbors I mean obviously that
there'd be danger to everyone who's
around everything I just described is
100 real and also 100 Unthinkable to
most Americans I mean to be honest for
for me
Trucking Park was my name
my innate children I'm being very honest
with you I've really really don't have
any fear for my life I'm not as scared
for myself but I was thinking like I was
like picturing every single possible
thing that could have happened to my
step children yes because I asked the
FBI I just learned about the details of
the assassination plot on Friday I
myself asked the leadership of the FBI
in the headquarter in in New York that
what really happened that I'm alive you
have to tell me and they said that
um basically we were watching you but
you were lucky as well because you
didn't open the door oh my God
because I they showed me the way that
they did they uh actually uh showed me
the the text messages that they've been
communicating three people one of them
yeah one of them amiroth was in Iran and
then Matthew was in front of my house
text him text him text uh text it
texting texting oh my God it's not easy
to talk about these things yeah next
thing too amirofin Iran saying that
as soon as she steps out
it's going to be done well that's awful
another text message was like go and ask
her for a flower from her garden
believe me if I opened had opened the
door and he was like asking me can I
have flour from your garden immediately
I would have said yes because you have
to go and ask my neighbors I'm very well
known in my neighborhood not because of
my activities mostly about my garden I'm
a village girl so I grow vegetables
sunflowers mint Basils and I offer flour
mints sunflowers to my neighbors so I'm
known for that it shows you that the
Iranian regime hired private
investigators
to uh follow me to to know my uh my life
and everything my body language my
everything so that's why it's so scary
because I myself know that many Iranians
are being denied Visa how come these
terrorists are welcomed here and how
come they rear that close to me
if you know me you know that I believe
we should own our own data and right now
big tech companies are tracking your
every move online one way you can
improve this situation is to use
expressvpn I like expressvpn and use it
on several devices you can use it for
under seven bucks a month after all I
don't want my personal data to get
access for the profit of someone else
plus I like being able to access content
from around the world just literally tap
one button on your device to turn it on
and you're done no more big companies
snooping around my business if you don't
like big Tech tracking you and selling
your personal data for profit it's time
to fight back visit expressvpn.com right
now to get three months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com Yang once more
expressvpn.com yang
foreign
[Music]
you're incredibly Brave they've clearly
been targeting you for years they've
sent assassins to kill you they have
intimidated and imprisoned family
members I understand that now some of
them are free on the condition that they
never talk to you my family yeah can you
believe that like it's awful my mom is
72 years old my mom has nothing to do
with my campaign against sure first
hijab because she wears her job this is
beautiful my mom wearing her job sharing
her love with me not she knows that I
don't want to wear her job and I hate
compulsory hijab but this is the the
nature of the Islamic Republic they
don't want us me and my mom to share
loves because that could be an example
to everyone that see mother and daughter
wearing hijab not wearing her job there
together so that's why they integrated
my mother
and and putting pressure on her to ask
her to to do to denounce me my mom said
that if you come back to my house again
I would set fire
I'd rather kill myself but I'm not gonna
denounce my dude oh my my gosh
and that's why
they arrested my brother
and they put him in prison for two years
and I cannot believe that in 21st
century I'm talking about
like why should I be away from my family
and why should I
um
sorry I'm very sorry well of course I'm
a strong
but I miss my mother
so and then they
put pressure on my family to take me to
Turkey
my brother exposed the plan my brother
just uh called me and said that if mom
and dad asked you to come to Turkey to
reunite to hug you say no because this
is from intelligent service
and they arrested my brother they
brought my sister on TV
to denounce me publicly I was watching
my sister for 17 minutes you know that
you're 17 minutes on TV it's a lot
hearing my sister like a disowning me
publicly this is you know this is this
is the Islamic Republic like Isis
atrocious and evil as is the response to
the women-led protests that have been
uh sweeping Iran for the last number of
now months uh and it was in the news
during the World Cup I mean that the
media is a strange thing where it will
Spotlight things uh
um arbitrarily and to your point it
shouldn't require people dying uh for
for uh for us to care about Iran and
about women of Iran
um but people are dying uh where the
Iranian government has been imprisoning
protesters has been uh raping and
executing prisoners 19
000 got arrested in four months
700 people got killed
in four months
50 innocent protesters are in the death
row and five of them got executed can
you believe that like um uh mohsen
shekari Majid
Muhammad husseini they were only 20 year
old 21 Young
and they forced them to do false
confession and then after that early
morning right after the uh
they went to their cell and said that
are you ready to be executed and they
did
for the crime of peacefully protesting
and demanding Freedom they actually
executing men for the crime of
supporting their sisters
and women are in prison being raped you
know for for years and years
um when women of Iran were saying that
compulsory her job is the most visible
symbol of Oppression
many
people in the west that didn't want to
pay attention to this because of you
know they were worried to cause
islamophobia many of them were saying
that this is part of your culture we
don't want to talk about it
but this is it now women are paying huge
price their life they're demonstrating
just how yeah how badly they want to be
able to choose yeah but this is now
Beyond it's going Beyond hijab because
for us Iranians as I said before
compulsory a job is just one one like
main pillar of a religious dictatorship
uh the Islamic Republic actually wrote
its own ideology on our body I mean the
only way that when you go to Iran and
Afghanistan that you understand that
these are the countries under the
control of Islamic States Taliban
Islamic Republic and Isis they're the
same it's just through us women you
remember the first picture when um uh
Taliban took over Afghanistan was what
women covering their face
and the other side the first picture
when women got free from Isis women
burning head scarves so now this is
happening in Iran when women are burning
their headscarves it means that we had
enough enough is enough we want to get
rid of Islamic Republic
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I've always been into sleep as one of
the best ways you can invest in your own
health and the way you can sleep better
is by getting a new mattress from Helix
sleep just take a personalized quiz at
helixsleep.com and they will send you a
mattress out of their 14 individual
mattress types that will give you the
sleep of your life and if you don't like
it you can return it risk-free for up to
a hundred nights I know it's bananas
Helix has been awarded the number one
mattress pick by GQ wired and my kids
who seek it out it's their favorite
mattress in the house and there are some
mattresses that frankly I spent more
money on than the Helix mattress Helix
is offering up to 350 off that's a
bigger amount than ever all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com slash
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
[Music]
one of the the things you want to see is
for the EU to designate the Iranian
National Guard as a terrorist group they
are really
for Iranians I'm being very clear of
course my people are getting killed
women are being shot in their faces
many women lost their eyes many men
young men being blinded
by revolutionary guards in 2019 the
Iranian regime shut down the internet
and killed um 1500 people only in three
days this is the Revolutionary guards
only in three days
and what happened
the whole world didn't do anything
revolutionary guards still are not being
designated as a terrorist organization
that's why they you know have no reason
to stop killing people inside Iran but
the revolution regards
is the one sending drones to Putin to
kill innocent ukrainians so you see
for us Iranians it's clear that
revolutionary guards is a terrorist
organization but I don't get it how come
that the West isolate poutine
but when it comes to Harmony who is
helping Putin to kill innocent
ukrainians then they hesitated to put
revolutionary guards in the terrorist
list I don't really get that the
Revolutionary guards is a threat to
people in Iraq in Syria in Yemen is a
threat for the whole region so that's
why I asked um President Biden for a
meeting in person to ask him actually to
take the lead because uh United State of
America
put their revolutionary guards in the
terrorist list and they have the power
they can actually uh
convince their own allies the EU to do
the same oh well certainly you'd be a
very compelling figure for the president
to meet with given the price that you
and your family are have already paid in
in many ways to make this case for the
the people of Iran uh I sure I speak for
most uh most any uh American when I say
that I hope that the Iranian people get
the the freedom that they want uh what
is happening right now on the ground
because
it seems that the current regime is
being very very uh heavy-handed and
doubling down and tripling down
um and yet I've also seen the videos of
the protesters in the hundreds the
thousands young women children in some
cases like every day Iranians really
risking everything because they want a
better way of life what is happening now
and what could the American people
um do to help that's a very good
question because when it comes to
politicians they actually saying that
when we see the level of violence is
very intense then we have to pay
attention but look we are in the middle
of Revolution and we see that innocent
people children teenagers are getting
killed so they have to understand that
this revolution has different phases
different forms the first way was like
massive protests across Iran every day
in other phases now the well-known
athletes in Iran quitting their jobs
saying that we don't want to be part of
propaganda 2 anymore well-known actress
um like removing their hijab saying that
we don't want to normalize this regime
anymore
we this was the first time in our
history that we see sense of unity among
oppositions inside and outside Iran
sense of unity between Kurds baluch Turk
Arabs and everywhere men and women so
and I strongly believe that now this is
the time that oppositions are getting
United to have a united front coalition
and we're trying actually by myself
working with many opposition figures
opposition leaders
um to convince the leaders of G7 to meet
with uh political oppositions wow and
recognize this Progressive revolution in
Iran in isolate the Islamic Republic
because look this is 21st century we the
people of Iran deserve to have a secular
Democratic regime but that's not fair
for the leaders of uh Democratic
countries to sit down and say that okay
we're waiting for you to go to the
streets and get killed change this
regime no this is not going to happen
like this you have to send a signal when
people are getting killed but you're
sending billions of dollars to the same
regime through um nuclear deal and
negotiating with the same murderers
nothing can happen
so for me and millions of Iranians it's
clear that we are ready to have an Iran
without the Islamic Republic we want to
get rid of this barbaric regime who
rapes women who kill children but we
want the leaders of democratic countries
to stand in the right side of the
history they have to expel the Islamic
Republic diplomats
they have to recall their ambassadors
they have to designate revolutionary
guards as a terrorist list
and instead of shaking the hand of these
murderers they have to shake the hand of
Iranians
I mean I don't think this is too much to
ask but I think that Americans can help
us
how
they have to understand that when it
comes to Islamic Republic this should be
a bipartisan issue yes I want to give
you an example
in my neighborhood there are people who
are supporting Trump some people
supporting President Biden I see the
signs yeah and
we see people are supporting that
they're left liberals right wing but hey
when it comes to me and my safety they
all give me hug they all saying that
Mercy we are with you Brooklyn is strong
we are united
because they don't care about my
political views this is a national
security issue this is this is about the
safety of Americans so it's not about
Iranians Islamic Republic is a threat
for America they say death to America
when they want to kill you believe me
they never ask you whether you're
Republican or Democrat they kill you
anyway so that is why I strongly believe
that my sisters in America Global
feminist movement who were chanting my
body my choice where are you we need
your support you can be allies for the
women of Iran and put pressure on
President Biden and America's Beacon of
Hope for Iranians and this is a
historical moment one of the most
Progressive Revolution is taking place
and I think that America can do a lot
they can take the lead the way that they
did beautifully to kick out the Islamic
Republic from United Nations top women's
body can you believe that in 21st
century Iranian government had to see
that the United Nation to monitor
women's rights globally so America did
that they can do more that's why I want
to talk in person with President Biden
and I deserve actually to have
this opportunity because I told you
before this conversation the reason that
I came here was because I was invited by
Obama's administration to interview him
but it was during 2009 green movement so
and he canceled that because they didn't
want to support green movement they
didn't want to send wrong signal to
Islamic Republic what happened
Obama said regret so I'm asking
President Biden to support Iranian women
now otherwise you're going to regret
again as as just about any American
would share the fact that they targeted
you an American on American soil uh is
just shocking and Beyond the panel and
it shows that there really is no limit
to what the Iranian government will
consider uh to suppress and oppress its
own people it was not even just me the
Iranian regime targeted the former
officials here
uh Mike Pompeo Brian hook uh Rudy
Giuliani I think and many other Iranian
dissidents and it's not only here in
America right now that I'm talking to
you the UK citizen U.S citizen
the Swedish citizen German citizen
French citizen they're all are in
Iranian prison and they're being used
like bargaining chip that's terrible so
imagine a day imagine a day that all the
leaders of democratic countries get
United in Australian regime instead of
just saying that okay let's negotiate no
the example public understand only one
language language of pressure put
pressure on them downgrade your
diplomatic relation and ask the Iranian
regime to release all the political
prisoners all the innocent prisoners
that that's how it works not just saying
that okay you know we are all for human
rights in America we are all for
equality in Europe we are for democracy
but you are not as
United as dictators Putin and Harmony
madora China everywhere dictators are
more united than Democratic countries
that's not acceptable we have to be
United against autocracy and dictators
yeah you made this case at the world
economic Forum very recently uh and and
how was that experience in Davos oh my
God
I had a hard time actually to get clear
answer from the chancellor of Germany
because I actually asked him clear
question that why why don't you put the
Revolutionary guards in the terrorist
list
isn't that the terrorist organization
killing people German citizens are being
now integrated by this regime didn't get
a clear response because it was like you
know we're working with our allies
friend French government uh yeah we
condemned that we sanction but this is
not going to work look even
um people inside Iran they say that
we're ready to die but we're not going
to give up
even even teenagers writing on their
social media saying that this might be
our last day well terrible yeah because
look they want to have normal life
one of the woman you know what she she
said to me she sent a video of herself
walking unveiled and she said that my
mom is scared that I'm gonna be another
massage and I told my mom that mom
you're worried that I'm gonna get killed
like myself I'm already a dead person
when I don't have freedom when I don't
have freedom to choose what I want to
wear when I don't have freedom to dance
when I don't have freedom to sing when I
don't have freedom to go to Stadium I'm
a dead person
this is the true face of the Islamic
Republican revolutionary guards so in
World economic from I I gave them a
pretty good picture of what's going on
in Iran but sometimes
I don't know money
I don't know what like
business what stopped the leaders of G7
to get United and do their duty to
support democracy to protect democracy
on one level I'm glad that you were
there to make the case uh I've never
been to Davos and people sometimes ask
me like hey uh what's it like and I was
like I don't know I've never been so on
one hand I was I was glad they invited
you uh on the other hand you know it
doesn't seem like they got the message
though hopefully I hope they're gonna
get it look
the government took everything away from
us Iranians but not hope
I've been shouting for years and years
that
we have to get United but I see a change
of
um like I see that the the leaders of
the democratic countries finally they're
changing their tone but we need we need
more concrete actions I'm hopeful that
finally uh they're hearing us I've been
mystified by the relative lack of both
media and political support and
attention for what's happening in Iran
women's rights are human rights and
what's happening to Iranian women and
children is unconscionable and shocks uh
just about any American who has seen
what's happening
um and hopefully we can help change that
here uh for both the media and
our political leaders that as any person
of conscience you want the people of
Iran to live the live the kind of lives
that they deserve to live with basic
human rights and freedom and and not
live in fear and not be
detained and
yeah and have a normal life uh and Iran
has become a very dark nefarious actor
on the world stage and in various ways I
just interviewed an American who's now
an enlisted Ukrainian Soldier and she
also talked about the fact that they're
not just fighting Russia they're
fighting uh Iran Iranian drones uh and
and some other armaments you were such
an incredible inspiration and leader uh
masi I mean talking to you is Ben uh
both uplifting and somewhat frankly uh
you know infuriating uh for me over this
past number of minutes because uh you're
so clearly passionate um you speak for
so many people
um there's just so much evil and
unnecessary pain and suffering that
that's happening in Iran and uh you hope
that courage and character gets rewarded
um and I hope in this case on behalf of
everyone listening I'm sure everyone
agrees like I hope that it is rewarded
by The Sweep of History yes I'm very
hopeful and I believe that
um Americans
can be uh
huge help because uh what Iranian women
are doing it's not just for themselves
Iranian women are sacrificing their life
because they're trying to protect
democracy and they're trying to save the
rest of the world from one of the most
dangerous virus which is called Islamic
regime and don't forget during from the
beginning when the covid-19 it was huge
everywhere people were like you know
it's gonna just stay in China it's gonna
just stay in Iran it didn't infected the
rest of the world Islamic Republic is
more deadlier than this they're gonna
spread everywhere so if
if the world ignore Iranian women
believe me they have to face those
terrorists on U.S soil more and more and
we the people of Iran are better allies
than these backward mullahs for America
and for the the EU so that is why I I
believe that
this is the time the time has come that
we should get United to protect
democracy amen well your belief in
America uplifts me uh if someone wants
to support your efforts or you
personally aside from letting their
congressperson know hey we should be
doing much much more to support the
Iranian people what can they do they can
do a lot look on social media I'm being
very honest with you we're being
bombarded systematically I'm being
harassed I'm being bullied
um the Iranian regime is really good at
setting their narrative to mainstream
media to
um you know to manipulate everything I
want the Americans to help me to get the
attention of tech companies that when
Iranians do not have free internet then
why why the dictators are being welcomed
on social media when Harmony banned 18
million people from using Twitter
Facebook Instagram then how come the
tech companies the U.S tech companies
giving Ibrahimovic verified account on
Instagram that makes me Furious and look
I met Cheryl Sandberg I met the leaders
of Instagram meta
but they are friends
I don't get why I cannot convince them
that when Harmony and Ibrahimovic
arresting people for using Twitter for
expressing themselves on Instagram when
Instagram and Twitter are banned for
Iranian then why you give them verified
account when President Trump was uh you
know banned from Twitter
everyone was celebrating left and
liberals then when I asked them to help
me to kick out Harmony they was like no
because of freedom of speech we have to
listen to what the leaders of your
country say say I said you really want
to listen to what they say they say Go
and Kill Them All Go and Kill Americans
let's eliminate Israel let's kill Salman
this is what they say so you want to
give them platform to order Massacre
that's why I believe that every ordinary
Americans who listen to me you can use
your social media put pressure on the
tech companies and say that ban Harmony
kick them out and provide more starting
free internet for Iran because internet
can save lives when people are being
executed being in prison tortured raped
they need to exchange information they
need to communicate but only the leaders
the dictators of Iran are able to enjoy
freedom of expression through American
tech companies I don't get this
hypocrisy that is perverse uh well Mossy
would love to be helpful in any way we
can I don't think this is a partisan
issue or even an American issue I think
it's a human issue thank you for your
courage and for standing up for Humanity
uh really and uh and we will do
everything we can to help get this
message out because it's so important
and hopefully we can help change the
reality for millions of Iranian women
and children and men and everyone who
cares about Humanity in the days to come
thank you so much for hosting me and I
believe together we are stronger I I
have hope that I can invite you one day
to my beloved country Iran you're going
to enjoy it masi you're you emanate a
certain uh energy and anything you
envision I think will happen yes I know
that thank you so much see you soon in
Iran how about that
[Music]